[Music]
I'm here today because three previous
boards have held up
what President Donald Trump has done is
wrong I'm here to show my state
representative politicians my teachers
everyone around me that this is an
important issue that this needs to be
talked about and that business to be
fixed it will impact me in the way that
it'll make it harder for me to get
financial aid from my school I won't be
able to work I won't be able to sustain
myself I won't be able it'll be more
difficult for me to travel it'll it'll
put me and my sister more at risk and
it'll be a fear I I have to keep living
with I still live with it and Becca has
helped but like it's still a fear I
emigrated when I was six months old I
was raised in Mesa Arizona almost my
whole life I know nothing but this
country so I consider this my home I'm
here today to fight for my community for
my parents for my brother I am here
because I think it's important to create
awareness and to show the SCOTUS and
Donald Trump that we're not going away
anytime soon if doctors taking away my
biggest fear is graduating college and
not being able to pursue the career that
I want to do because I need that social
security number I need that
identification could be able to continue
to work and even after I graduate I
might have to go back to doing the jobs
that are under the table going back to
housekeeping and although those are very
valuable jobs and they pay for for what
we have - there's more than that I don't
want to live in fear every single day I
don't want to count how much time I have
left in this country I want to feel
comfortable I want to thrive I want to
see be successful be someone in life and
hopefully if the u.s. lets me contribute
[Music]
if it's not taken away
I mean I'm gonna continue what I'm doing
I'm going to continue my activism
because doctor does give me protections
from deportation but even then that's
not enough it's just a band-aid like I
said I'll never be a citizen I'll never
be able to bow we need a pathway to
citizenship so even if daca isn't taken
away we're not done there the fight
continues this is just a temporary
band-aid and we need more than that
[Music]
[Music]
you